for those of you keeping score at home
last week was one for the Reuben report
record books our week started off by
interviewing Senator John McCain a war
hero one of the longest-serving members
of Congress and a Republican nominee for
president of the United States Senator
McCain and I had a frank discussion on
this year's election money in politics
and foreign policy what struck me more
than anything while talking to the
senator was whether you agree or
disagree with his political opinions
it's clear that he's really trying to
bridge the ideological divide and do
what he feels is right for the country
the entire time I was talking to him I
kept thinking what a better candidate
Senator McCain would be than any of the
current contenders in the GOP rat race
immediately after interviewing Senator
McCain I had the chance to interview
Lubner
Ahmed luma is a 23 year old engineering
student and an atheist fighting for
secular values in her homeland of Iraq
simply by talking to me about secularism
from the confines of her closed society
she instantly became braver than pretty
much every person that I know I'm
honored that she chose me as the first
public person to talk to and I'll always
be an ally for her whether she's in Iraq
or wherever life takes her while I was
in awe of her during the interview the
most impactful part to me was when we
talked about some of the people that we
both admire including sam harris and
richard dawkins this portion of our chat
illuminated exactly what this show is
about ideas the same ideas that Sam and
Richard sparked in me a 39 year old guy
born in Brooklyn living in Los Angeles
also were sparked in Lubner
a 23 year old atheist in Iraq this shows
you the true power of ideas good or bad
ideas can transcend nationality race or
religion my final interview last week
was with the former leader of the
English Defence League and now outspoken
anti immigration activist Tommy Robinson
as I mentioned at the top of the show
last week I was hesitant to even talk to
Tommy
because people might call me a bigot or
a racist not only my glad that we did
the interview but I'm really proud of
your reaction to it whether on YouTube
Twitter or Facebook you guys all kept
the conversation going after Tommy and I
put
down it was complete and total
confirmation of last week's direct
message being afraid to talk can no
longer be part of the equation I have no
doubt there is a real movement happening
right now people are absolutely sick of
being divided conversation is the key to
bringing us together and that's why in
one week I talked to a man who is almost
the leader of the free world a woman who
puts her life on the line to say what
she believes and another man who's on a
crusade of his own it's totally
irrelevant whether I agree with
everything my guests say the important
thing is to not be afraid to hear them
as the internet brings us all closer
together we find ourselves connected
with people in a way that we could have
only dreamt of a couple years ago
despite that connection I still get
messages from viewers explaining that
sometimes you guys are afraid to say
certain things to your friends in real
life or to post certain articles on
Facebook for all to see if Lubner a 23
year old in Iraq isn't afraid to speak
up then you guys can't be either there's
no time for silence anymore yeah there
are genuinely bad people in the world
and sometimes talking to them won't get
you the results you want however you
have to be brave enough to have the
conversation in the first place
don't let louder voices with worse
intentions drown you out all right
according to Wikipedia my guest this
week is either the former king of
Mesopotamia or youtuber not afraid to
speak his mind on controversial topics
that's right I have Karl Benjamin better
known as Sargon of Akkad on the show
Karl Sargon what I call you would Jimmy
once I get cold both all day long so
whichever one you'll come Sargon has
sort of overtaken Karl there's sort of a
Batman Bruce Wayne situation here right
you know that kind of is actually ads
it's what the the name songul has
definitely um traveled before me in many
places where um progressives tend to
congregate you said progressives I'm
shocked that you didn't say regressives
but we'll get to that momentarily
so before we get into all the the deep
stuff and the topics and the meat of
this I want people to get to know you a
little bit
because I think it's sort of just
recently that you're showing your face
more you're out there more your name's
getting out there a little bit more so
how did Carl Benjamin become sargon of
akkad um so that's an interesting
interesting story it's not actually that
interesting it's all now Sarah um that
will it just make it interesting how
about that I'll try I'll try and I'll
try and fabricate something um no
basically about about two and a half
years ago I you know you you know when
you're on the internet you end up I'm
just choosing the moniker that you sign
in two places with and I just happen to
like the historical figure of Salman I
can use an interesting figure I like the
sound of the name and you know so I was
just using that and I had signed up to
YouTube um in 2010 just to upload some
videos of myself with an ancient sling
you know the sort of verb I you know
made one yeah I called historical sort
of documents and I tested it out and
it's that you can see why the dangerous
weapons something and then a few years
later I was basically getting really
really worried about the the sort of
political climate in the left I was
starting to see more and more often um
just my own principles being completely
violated and it was really really really
worrying and it was something that was
genuinely starting to nor me because I
mean I would see people arguing for
arguing against people's freedom of
speech or they would be arguing against
a meritocratic system so some allama and
everyone would seem to be going along
with it this this was you know there was
so many people going yet that's exactly
how we should do things our slows palek
thinking christ i totally disagree in
fact I disagree on such a fundamental
level I have to say something and so I
found myself just motivated source right
uh just like under five minutes scripts
or something and then read them with a
very very bad microphone then I mean I
gets all about the mic
it really is it's it's a it's a
magician's trick almost I had just the
cheapo microphone it was really really
terrible quality and I'd read these
ideas and they started gaining some
Jesus like people started subscribe to
my channel stuff and looking back now
I'm thinking god they were really there
was a lot of forbearance there about my
technical skills and what I was saying
but I guess some people agreed with what
I'm saying because now I've
I just Passport quarter of a million
subscribers yeah happens yeah and now I
do this full-time and it's a it's a
wonderful thing to be doing is fighting
for my principles special so I love that
I love that because as I say on the show
every week what I'm trying to do here is
make this about ideas and that's really
what you were talking about you were
hearing bad ideas and then you wanted to
beat them with better ideas and clearly
it's working because you got over
250,000 subscribers and and when I had
my personal awakening because everyone
knows at this point you know I've always
considered myself liberal then I was in
the progressive world which I now see as
some sort of mental disorder but when I
was having my Awakening out of that
everyone online said to me you've got to
talk to Sargon so my so my first
question to you before we get into the
the heavy stuff is did you study
politics what brought you into the
political realm I didn't it was um it
was just watching my news I guess and
just watching
you know popular I mean I used to be I
used to be a big fan of The Young Turks
I used to consider myself progressive
until I met progressives and like I said
I I couldn't believe the things they
were saying it really struck me as some
sort of mental disorder yeah why would
they start saying things like this and
yeah and then I then I thought I found
myself sort of floundering on my own
because I you know this I'm not
conservative I I can't I can't bring
myself to subscribe to conservative
ideas I think just don't they don't work
me I don't I don't believe in and so I
was basically on my own you know
everyone I knew was it was a liberal was
quite happy to ignore the foundational
principles of liberalism in order to in
order to push progressivism further and
the more the more I've learned about
progressivism the more I realize it's
really used liberalism as a Trojan horse
to you know they've said oh we're
liberals with progressives and I mean on
the foot on the surface of it they're
not necessarily arguing for different
things it's it's really the methods that
the problem it's not necessarily the
goals um but yeah they happily use the
the terms interchangeably and they are
not
changeable [ __ ] yeah so let's let's
unpack that a little bit so I've heard
you say that you refer to yourself as a
classic liberal and the more that I've
been doing this I mean that's really
where I feel at home too I think now I
have some really strong libertarian
leanings also but there's there's some
there's some play there there's some
common ground there but what does
classic liberalism mean to you um well
it's just the it's just basic
enlightened values that came out of the
alignment the civil liberties political
freedom freedom of expression freedom
Association economic freedom
representative democracy rules law it's
all these just there is no argument
against these ideas these are great
ideas they're universal ideas you know
everyone is protected under these ideas
unlike with progressivism where the
first thing they will do is demarcate a
group they will say right women black
people gay people these people need
special treatment and that special
treatment will involve the infringement
of your personal rights and that is
where I have a problem because if we all
ascribe to the same rights a we're all
being treated as equals be nobody ends
up losing their rights and I don't have
a point see but I wish I did
I think that's covered in all the
reasons yeah that that was pretty good
so this is sort of an example of the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions right because this is where
I've seen I know a lot of progressives a
lot of them won't talk to me anymore
people that I that were my good friends
only you know six eight months ago that
won't talk to me anymore but I believe
that for the most part and we're going
to get into some of the really dangerous
ones but I think for the most part
people that consider themselves
progressive most of the people that are
going to Bernie Sanders rallies I think
are good people I think their intentions
are current so we're really talking
about the methodology here right yeah
there are a few the problem is you have
a bunch of you know a bunch of
motivating factors that kind of coalesce
and in mixed in with that you have the
more sort of pernicious aspects of
people who can see where this is going
because a lot of it involves giving the
benefit of the doubt to people who you
would otherwise necessarily be skeptical
to people making for example rape
one of the big progressive pushes and it
is is to have it certainly victim
quote-unquote the the alleged victim is
believed and therefore the burden of
proof becomes laid on the person who's
being accused rather than on the accuser
and they do this by the use of
statistics they say oh well you know I
come up with the number is but something
like I made five percent of accused
rapists go to jail or something like
that and therefore they assume that
there is a massive problem with the
system that 95 percent of accused
rapists are also actual rapist and
therefore just being let off through a
bad system but the thing is a we don't
know we have no idea how many of the
people who are accused are actually in
legitimate rapists and deserve to be
condemned for it and convicted for but
secondly what we're doing there is
reversing the system because at the
moment what we have is a system that
isn't perfect but can deliver justice in
a reliable way you know that we can be
quite sure that the people going to jail
probably aren't innocent you know we've
been through a rigorous rigorous trial
the burden of proof is on the accuser
they have managed to prove beyond
reasonable doubt and you know that's
fine because that way you're going to
get the minimum number of people who
didn't do anything wrong being punished
as if they did something wrong whereas
to flip the script on that would mean
that you now have a system that is
inherently unjust that might be able to
deliver justice on occasion the occasion
being the person being accused is on
camera somewhere else at the time that
they're supposed to have been doing the
rape or something like that you know
right it's that sort of thing it's it
would be incidental justice you know you
couldn't rely on it because you don't
presume the innocence of the people
being accused the guilt is being
presumed and it's being done like say
how good motives the idea that you know
we don't want to call the victims liars
and say no I I don't want to call the
victim a liar either but it's one of
those points where you're on the horns
of a dilemma and you have no choice but
to take a responsible course of action
fully safety of someone who hasn't done
anything wrong right so all right so
there there's a lot there that I wanna
know I've been preparing for this yeah
ya know you're jumping you're though I
knew that that's how this conversation
was going to go because there's so much
to talk about and then these things are
always inextricably linked that's what I
found
whenever I'm talking about anything
related to sort of regressive ideology
and then when you start talking about
feminism and Islamism and all these
things they're they're also in extra
inextricably linked so let's let's jump
into gamergate for a second and then
we'll get back to some of that stuff
because gamergate I think is one of the
things that really sort of put you on
the map and even by saying the word
gamergate I've made people crazy we know
this now I've discussed it with a couple
people I've had mileage innopolis on
I've talked about it with Christina Hoff
Sommers but you yourself you are a true
gamer correct yes I am indeed a true
game what do you play in these days I
play a game called Ark survival evolved
most actually have my own server where I
pay for a server where I get to run
around killing virtual dinosaurs it's
great Wow well thank you for taking a
moment from slaying dinosaurs to to join
me here but yeah you've really been in
the gamergate thing and I think are
considered sort of an expert on it so
can you give me like a 2-3 minute
explanation of what gamergate is and I
know that's almost impossible because it
seems like it's something different to
everybody it is I can give you my
version of what it is but like I say it
is different to everybody and you're
going to get people who are going to say
that's not what gamergate isn't whatnot
so um for me it is it's a very definite
reaction to regressives infiltrating the
video game media now this is something
that we saw we saw happening over the
course about five years where they were
just in criminal it just larger and
larger numbers of them would be hired at
various gaming publications and then
they would start writing articles like
are these video games sexist why are
these video games on sahjhan is there
are no trans people news video games
this is racist this is you know the this
kind of regressive lines yeah 101 yeah
and they would be promoting very famous
feminists like Anita sarkeesian or Zoe
Quinn people with and I don't I don't
want I mean but very few real
credentials in the video game industry
mean like zoe quinn what the the franz
ferdinand of gamergate she made a a free
digital did you
those choose our own adventure book I
love choose-your-own-adventure I
probably had everyone right yeah yeah
basically that's what she had made she
had made a digital chooser an adventure
book it was all all text no no nothing
else in it it can't take him very long
but it was about learning to deal with
depression and I might never have
depression so I can't judge the game on
that merits on that I'm sure it's very
good but your average gamer this wasn't
really a game there wasn't a failed
state you know wasn't there wasn't
really an T could play was more like an
interactive novel which is again it's in
itself fine but the gaming press because
she was a prominent feminist and
regressive she got unbelievable amounts
of coverage and I mean when I say
unbelievers mean any amount of coverage
for the app is more than you would
expect and so people kind of they were
getting sick of the agenda being pushed
on them and it's the same of the need
suck easier when a nice occasion did her
Kickstarter it was everywhere everyone
knew about it and yes everyone also knew
that the arguments she was presenting
were half-truths they were cherry-pick
they were she was finding individual
examples that didn't really represent
the gaming industry or any even you know
subsections of the gaming industry and
presenting them as if they were a
categoric statement on the condition of
the entire gaming industry and so
everyone was really color annoyed by
this point especially as the way that
these people work is by rolling up your
emotions so almost everything they say
is fundamentally accusatory they would
say things like you're a sexist you're a
racist if you like these games there
aren't enough you know black people in
this game right enough women in this
game gay people all the sort of thing
and if you're enjoying it you're a bad
person whereas most pop people thinking
well just hell just just make the games
you want to make right but that's not
what these people are interested in
whatsoever um and so got to the point
where Zoe Quinn that was courts having
an affair with her boss who is involved
in video games and also a journalist
called Nathan Grayson
and the video game industry's press has
always been corrupt and you know it's
always been crosses come out of a hobby
press it's always been really really bad
but this is when you say corrupt just to
pause for one sec will you say corrupt I
mean things like you know people paying
off the mag
in writers so that they'd get better
reviews on the game so they'd sell more
games I mean real corrupt stuff yeah
yeah and a lot of its in your face as
well so you go to a video game so online
magazine and that the backdrop would be
the advertisement for a game that then
would be reviewed in the center column
you know it's your it's not you know
it's not even then I'm trying to hide it
but for the most part nobody really
cared because they weren't being preachy
about you know they were trying to sell
you video games and that's what people
were there for and therefore nobody was
really that bothered but then that the
regressives turned up and started being
corrupt in a whole different way instead
of instead of being most flowed by money
which i suppose is to their credit they
were motivated by ideology and so now
they would hire people into positions
and promote things that were all based
on cronyism it was all their friends and
family members and whatnot they would
they would push everything to do with
their agenda and people realistically
people have just been really really sick
events but they were tired of this phone
moralism tired of being told that they
were bad people even though you know
obviously none of these people are
actually bad people mean and nobody
knows who all of these people are and
yeah they're being they're being pre
judged before anything happens and it
got to the point where people like look
know enough you know this has got to
stop and that's what what that was
basically it was called the quince
piracies salad and then the video game
press instead of turning around and
saying something like okay fair enough
we haven't been doing our due diligence
you know we a lot of them are
professional trained journalists like
Stephen - tiller from kotaku his
master's degree in journalism and he's
there saying well do we have to be
objective what's the need for objective
journalism and so you can instantly see
the problems that were inherent in the
video game industry yeah and I know we
can we can really go down the rabbit
hole yeah we could we could spend three
hours with this but I think that's I
think that's a nice little beginning
piece of it but what I really find
fascinating about it and why I've
brought it up several times is because
the same things that you're talking
about how the regressive sort of
infiltrated this and turned something
that had nothing to do with sexism or
racism or any of these things they made
it about that and I think when I was on
your show I was saying how I you know I
used to be a huge gamer I'm not that
much anymore but I like the community
and I do play some games here and there
but like you know I played grand theft
and yeah you could steal a car and punch
a hooker and people would say well
that's against women but you could also
punch a man so should they only have it
that you'd only punch men I mean even
the logic behind it doesn't really stand
to critique and there's no winning
either so this is the point of something
it's all what was called a katka trap
it's either you are this thing or you're
this thing you don't even realize it you
know and there's no falsifiability to
any of their hypotheses but the main
problem if you think about it look like
with grand theft auto so like what the
options not include women in the game no
way that they'd freak out if you
couldn't put women in the game right or
you can have the women not being able to
be treated like men again they'd be
freaking out that's not equal at all so
what I mean what are you gonna have you
have women so they just can't be damaged
or you know you they will not allow you
to treat women like men you know you
can't beat up women you can't but you
can beat up men and so you're in this
position whether you've got no win you
know there's no good answer and that's
how they want it they want you dancing
to their tune yeah and that's what
that's what's so fascinating about this
and why I think it's so related to the
political situation with the regressives
and I also think that's why gamergate
blew up the way it did because gamers
generally are going to skew a little
younger than the people that are solely
interested in politics so because of
that I think it was this group of people
who had never been used to being
attacked or silenced before and they
were young and they were online and they
were ready to coalesce around something
and I think that's what made it so so
magical or something you know gamers
gamers were actually long been the demon
in the in the bedroom for Len I felt
like the American Christians in the late
90s early 2000s there was I'm Hillary
Clinton and Joe Lieberman actually
brought legislation to try and try and
sort sensor video games so this is
another reason I would never vote for
Hillary I mean I don't think anyone ever
should she's a corporate shill don't
vote fail re yeah I mean there are so
many reasons Nazi basically really can
get into that too yeah yeah get gamers
are actually quite familiar with being
attacked politically because of their
hobby even though there hasn't been a
single study that's ever really
conclusively proven anything about
Vinnie
in fact there are there are dozens that
say well there's no connection between
video games and anything you know and if
you look at the statistics the rise of
video games has coincided with the
dissent of violence so I mean I'm not
saying they're connected but it's one of
those things there is literally nothing
to show that video games are doing
anything wrong in fact there's quite a
lot should the general are things well I
remember that I think maybe it was
around 91 or 92 when Joe Lieberman was
leading that that fight against video
games I think it was because of MORTAL
KOMBAT I was playing it on Sega Genesis
at the time and I would come home from
school and play that for hours with my
friends I never ripped anyone's call out
with their spine attached to it you know
any man punch not once now I tried once
but I yeah I never successfully did it
so that says something actually I think
you can prove that it probably helps
people in a more healthy way than some
of their anger and frustration don't you
think I think multiplayer games on there
you know they get they get groups of
guys to hang out and do something that's
not dangerous or violent you know thing
but I mean when I was a kid if we
weren't playing vidiians we were on the
streets you know right it was better for
us to be at home playing video games
than to not be playing video games so I
I honestly can't see where the
objections come from you know but it
wasn't it's the same with anything like
Dungeons and Dragons in the 80s or music
in the 70s you know video games in the
90s and the 2000s there is always
something that we you know poll
clutching moral majority or so they
would like to position themselves as has
got to rail against something and
ironically that was always the religious
right you know that was always the
highly religious authoritarian right now
it is the highly regressive
authoritarian laugh yeah and this is the
horse-shoe theory that we talk about all
the time that the extremes on both sides
come together all right so last thought
on gamergate you know the other thing
that i think is really nice about the
community is that people who are gamers
it doesn't matter what race you are it
doesn't matter what religion you are
what sex or sexuality any of the little
dividing boxes that the left wants to
put us in it doesn't matter what you are
and that's why the community is so
strong so then when when these people
that are writing these articles say well
gamers are sexist or gamers are racist
it actually it literally has no me
because it's as diverse a community as
you could possibly put out there right
yeah I mean it you literally can't tell
by playing a video game what race or
gender the people you're playing with
are because everyone gets to choose
their own avatar they get to customize
their name you know the only way you'd
know is by voice chat you know so for
the vast majority of people playing
video games is not tied to identity
politics and the you know what's
interesting is the regressive academics
actually did they spent a lot of time
sort of piling their assault on video
games and they spent a lot of time doing
research and there was an academic a
feminist academic called Adrian Shaw who
did a series of studies not based on
particularly large sample sizes but
large enough I would say to at least
give you the impression that they're
going the wrong direction because her
conclusions and she was someone looking
for a way to sort of you know crack open
the video game industry with a good
reason to attack it
she found that basically uh video games
didn't need diversity video games had
diversity last meant that you know that
and that in itself what where does a
regressive begin their a plan of attack
you know if they think they're attacking
is already diverse you know and so
basically it led to her reframing the
study she had already conducted in a
different way in the the language is
very opaque but some basically she was
not happy that there was a plurality of
markets and now I personally think a
plurality of markets is a wonderful
thing
I think Lina if you want a video if you
want video games about under Japanese
hentai great that's your business I'm
not interested in that I want I want
video games about killing dinosaurs
that's great that's my niche yeah
everyone gets their own niche you know
whereas the problem that they had is
that they wanted hegemony over they
didn't want a plurality of markets
because then you could have diverse
market you have markets aren't feathers
they wanted every market to be
controlled effectively by their ideology
and thankfully it's not going to happen
right so just to be clear about that so
there are people that are probably
playing Mario Kart that have nothing to
do with the people that are playing the
games you're playing so it doesn't make
sense even to lump all those people
together absolutely
'inna there will obviously be some
crossover in every every game genre but
by and large you get people who have
different preferences and they play
different things it's like um one of the
things they were saying one of the
things they the big static platters are
almost half of people playing video
games or women's okay great but what are
they playing they're not playing call of
duty you know they're not set they're on
their Xboxes but their headphones and
running around calling each other gay
ready no member they're playing candy
crush and farm Valen at which all
perfectly valid forms of entertainment
and more power to them I want them to
play the games they want to play but
these you know by this fact they it
doesn't justify changing anything about
the games I play because of the games
they play and vice versa is true I don't
want their games being changed to suit
me either you know that would be the
last thing I would want to impose on and
so this is basically one of the things
the regressive left will always do is
use statistics in the most slippery way
possible
you know lies damned lies and statistics
really does apply it you I mean they
they will use statistics to justify
anything so be be careful about the use
of Statistics with regressive laugh all
right so you've given me a perfect lane
through gamergate to talk about probably
your your other favorite thing to talk
about or at least maybe your most
controversial thing to talk about which
is feminism so let's let's go there
let's talk a little feminism I'm gonna
give you this in the most broad sense
basically you don't like what the
feminist movement has become is that
fair to say yes and the one one of the
dangers of talking about feminism is
that it's very often conflated with
women and this is done to wait we're not
exactly you're a misogynist yeah last
thing you'll hear if ever you have any
complaint about feminism um however I
mean this is just obviously logically
it's not it's not is nonsense feminism
itself as an ideology and you get male
and female feminists you get people who
are male and female opposed to modern
feminism so the idea that feminism is
inherently the same as women is
ridiculous and the thing is even the
fewer and fewer women every year are
identifying as feminists at the moment
in it in America only about 18%
of women identify as feminists and I
only some about 9% of men whereas in in
say the 70s somewhere as high as 40% so
the feminist movement is honestly I
think I don't think it's doing yourself
any favors I think it's it's gone full
regressive that's the problem you know I
I would have no problem calling myself a
feminist if we were in the era of say
second wave feminism we had you know
it's some equity feminism but christina
hoff sommers or Camille Paley would be
espousing you know this the sort of
equal rights equal pay or the sort of
all all sort of things that you as any
Galit Aryan would be completely on board
with and would find absolutely no
objection to I find objects into but my
problem is when we start getting into
the realms of well I mean shaming
language for a start you're a misogynist
you're this about you the other when you
have any objection and quotas or any
anything like this you know and then you
then get to some conspiracy theories
patriarchy Theory you know and then it
becomes intersectional so now involves
race and transsexuals and homosexuals
and and now it's a karaoke this is an
inter linking a series of oppressions
and privileges and really you realize
that what you what you're regurgitating
is Marxist rhetoric it's all I mean if
you read the communist manifesto you
understand modern feminism you're
talking about the male bourgeoisie and
the female proletariat and it's the same
with black and white straight and gay
and all these sort of things and I just
don't ascribe to that because it implies
a shared experience that we know men and
women don't have you know I mean and and
not just men and women like black people
near Trayvon Martin did not have the
same life experiences about Barack Obama
you know and so to say that being black
is some sort of inherent shared
oppression that they have is ridiculous
you know it just it doesn't work and my
main problem really is but is that it's
become anti individualistic the I mean
you get famous famous like any sakhis
and who will literally say things like
individuals women individual women's
choices don't count
what matters is what it what matters is
feminism or the great unit something for
the greater good of feminism something
that I can't over exactly how the the
quote goes but it was just one of those
things where it's just like okay I am so
totally against this that I think I'd be
prepared to fight a civil war against
you you know I think these are so anti
anti liberal principles I can't stand
them right so so in a way it's evolved
to where it's no longer first off women
are in a minority I think there's
something like 50 51 or 52 percent of
the population but where where you
should be for the minority in a minority
what you're saying is that their fight
it they're eliminating the minority in
the minority I think an example of that
we could use from the American political
space would be someone like Sarah Palin
now I don't like the views that Sarah
Palin espouses at all really but can you
believe that yeah I'm not a big fan of
Sarah Palin
that being said she's obviously a very
influential and powerful and
self-motivated woman so in a certain
sense she's the ultimate goal of what a
feminist should be but feminists hate
her right absolutely because she thinks
wrong that's the problem she she doesn't
espouse she doesn't spell regressive
ideology she doesn't I mean if she
called herself a feminist fundamentally
she wouldn't be invoking Marxist ideas
she would be invoking sort of
libertarian ideas on the strength of the
individual hard work you know the all
these honestly I think that you know
they're not they're not bad ideas at all
but she wouldn't be in the same camp as
say Gloria Steinem
Steinem or bell hooks or someone like
that yeah and I I don't it's weird
talking about Marxism you know it's
really weird because I mean almost
nobody really understands it these days
but and many people understand it other
academics and universities who teach it
and it is the Communist Manifesto is the
third most prescribed book in
universities in America just you know
the Communist Manifesto communism died
everywhere but in the West it's so
bizarre
well we fetishize these things right
absolutely be people who live under
communism hate communism they think it's
a terrible idea they know that I mean
they they had secured at 3:00 in the
morning for milk and eggs you know they
think is a terrible idea but the people
in the West have never lived through it
being put into practice and so they
don't understand it's you know they
don't really mean this orally understand
the real true nature of it I guess and
so you know when you're sat in a
comfortable house that's been built
under a capitalistic system and you've
got lots of money you've you're doing
very well for yourself you're thinking
well maybe we should you know maybe
maybe it's not such a bad idea and right
it is it you know and but it's these
principles that inform almost everything
about third wave feminism it's all about
it's all about power dynamics privileged
and oppressed privilege and oppress
which is why I was watching The Young
Turks the other day in fact and a jimmy
dore i think it was he he actually had
his tongue in his mouth and he was
saying that some he was for the
oppressed in every situation so he took
the example of israel so in israel
oppressed as a Palestinian man he's in
Federalist inian man and then if the
Palestinian man oppresses his wife he's
in favor of the wife and it's just like
you but that you've you've just said you
are and are not in favor of the
Palestinian man there Jimmy
you know that is inherited country you
can't you can't be in favor of the man
and the wife you know at the same time
which one are you in favor of you know
it's it's that kind of it's got this
inherent contradiction to it and they
don't seem to want to acknowledge that
yeah and that's why as we've said for a
while now this this regressive ideology
it's always putting narrative over fact
use that's really the most when you
Whittle it down to what it really is it
has to be narrative over fact so you
just pick the most depressed and then
you get everybody on the ladder and then
that's how you judge everybody which is
the reverse of judging a minority within
a minority and those are the people that
we should be for yeah absolutely in the
the crazy thing about it as well is that
these things are inherently racist and
sexist you know any other issue you want
to but the the problem is that normally
when people think are you being a racist
you think you're being a racist to the I
guess the the oppressed if that's what
you want to come you know the minority
who have suffered from racial
discrimination passed you know it will
black people or you know you pressing
women or something like that but racism
and sexism despite what the regressors
will tell you are not structures or
systems of power their principles their
ideas they are there they are ways of
viewing the world and so you can be
racist to white people you can be sexist
to men
vice versa and so it's this kind of
unlikely as the narrative they've got
out of the way to redefine a bunch of
words and then they have cherry-picked
data points to arrive a nice location
where they can say you as a white man
and not now allowed to speak why because
you're a white man and they will
literally turn around and tell you that
that is not racist and sexist I think
it's amazing you give them enough credit
to say they've picked these data points
because I I think in most cases they
haven't even gone that far you're giving
them the benefit of the doubt that I can
no longer give them but we started here
on feminism so let's not go too far but
but that's the interesting thing that
every time I'm talking about all this
stuff we realize how the inter there's
this interleague theme between gamergate
between feminism all of this stuff so as
far as feminism I saw an interesting
video that you did where you took the
the three types of what you said were
the three types of male feminists um and
I thought it was really interesting
because I was because I defend women
women should be equal and that's pretty
much it so you anyone can define me
however they want but I thought the way
you broke these three type of men down
was pretty interesting can you do that
for us um I thought it was while ago in
that video I can't remembering um okay
so yeah it's basically about
self-interest I think I mean you get
some you get men who are they they want
to be rewarded for doing something
heroic and protective you know it's and
I think that chain might fall into this
category where he's a big guy he's not
he himself that you know that this chap
doesn't have any particular um fears in
for his own physical security and so he
thinks so I'm going to use my physical
presence to protect women because that
would be a you know laudable thing to do
and it would be except that they're
doing it for their own self-interest
they're doing it their own to their own
personal feelings um these are at the
end of the day this is a guy who
basically wants to get laid I mean in a
lot of respects I don't have put it that
way but yeah I mean kind of it is and
the things it's not necessarily getting
lady that I love a lot of it is just for
um just for the sort of the emotional
reward you know because my social cred
yeah yeah and
and just um just to get the pat on the
head you know it's it's not kind of to
feel good about themselves but requires
permission from someone else this case
being one and the thing is you end up
you end up getting release or them
really unhealthy dynamics because you'll
find women who are looking for men to do
things for and you will find men who are
looking to do things for women and you
will get this kind of feedback loop
where they'll reinforce each other you
know you there's this this guy stands up
for this woman who is using him to fight
her battles and so this guy ends up
fighting battles on his battles but are
being reinforced constantly by and again
this is not like all women in fact most
women are not like this but you will you
know women are humans too and you get
bad women as well as good women and you
find that this this is basically one of
the problems with them the progressives
because like we were saying earlier and
I hate to come back to like progresses
but feminism is just one like branch
under the umbrella of the progressive
sort of tree I guess you know it's it
all ties together um
but you like said you get most people
they think they're doing it for the
right reasons you know they think well
I'm a good person I need to be helping
women and minorities and gays and trans
Maya but the the problem is that they
they have this kind of toolbox of
rhetoric that there are two signals to
other regressives it shows them say hey
look I'm using this kind of language
therefore I'm on your team you can come
and support me on Twitter aware Amina
and and so you get people who think okay
great I'm going to do that because I
want to be an activist or do something
good
and then you'll get the other kind of
person who is the more malicious person
who will think great I can use this to
my own advantage and they are the people
you've got to be really worried about I
mean that there's in gamergate there was
a woman called Randy Hart but she wasn't
actually part of game day she's part the
problem but some the I've never seen it
more starkly represented than in her
example I think the thing was 2011-2012
she she was on a BSD which is a
programming language of podcast and she
was literally saying well I'm a woman in
tech and I don't have a problem with
this you know I think I think the
feminists are way over blowing this
problem with misogyny in the tech
industry and also stuff I'm a woman
attack I have no problem everything's
great
and lo and behold two years later when
it's shown to be a profitable business
model she is literally on Twitter saying
I'm an oppressed woman in tech I need
your money you know give me money every
month through patreon and also and it it
just the complete polar opposite of what
you're saying before and it's like
really so either the industry has become
massively sexist overnight right you
found a way to profit you know and so so
this is sort of something we could find
with any movement so I don't think I
don't think you're saying this but that
this isn't specific to feminism any
movements going to have it's people who
are doing it with the right intentions
it's going to have the people that are
being guilted into it it's going to have
the people that are being tricked into
it it's gonna have the people that can
profit from it or every single movement
and you're just using feminism as one
example I don't want people to say well
you see he's trying to muck up what
feminism is or something to that effect
ya know it's you right this this is and
again it's not necessary feminism
because feminism is just a subsection of
the social justice movement you know
you've got some they they call it into
sectionalism which is um like there's a
reason bell hooks describes it as the
white supremacist capitalist patriarchy
and that's a surprising you you are you
are a supporter of the white supremacist
capitalist patriarchy day yeah in fact I
actively propagates I'm a terrible
person but basically what this
encompasses is the dynamics between
black people and white people the white
supremacy the capitalism is the poor and
rich and the patriarchy being men and
women and I think they probably have
terms for gay and straight and trans and
sis but I'm not familiar with them off
my head but this is this is the point
it's um they have this toolbox of terms
and they have a big academic backing all
of this comes from academia all of it
you know this is all been and people
think oh this is coming from tumblr so
no tumblr is the outgrowth it's cancer
you know the this is it coming to the
surface in popular culture this all
comes from sort of you know the brightly
lit halls of academia where they they
start with a premise they confirm their
biases they peer review their own papers
between feminists and then they carry on
building from that until they've got to
the point where they will and it like I
said the redefinition of things the
reason the reason regressives are so
dangerous is of course as you said with
every movement you're going to get
people who are profiteering you need
people doing their own selfish reasons
but I can't think of any movement that
legitimately has an excuse to be
malevolent to people for any good reason
you know almost every single Ally like
the Christie is about love you love your
neighbor as yourself you know and look
further individualist is seen at
individual rights and represented
democracy everyone gets to be treated in
a universal manney you know the
brotherhood of man all that sort of
thing whereas these people have
something different they actually have
and I come up which feminists it is and
I'm quoting when they say this I think
it's Andrea Dworkin when they say that
women have the right to hate their
oppressors now this is for me a
particularly scary aspect of it and it
goes it goes entirely for what the black
lives matter movement who all subscribe
to this kind of ideology it's the it's
the way of legitimizing hatred for
people based on what is perceived to be
social advantages so if they say well
you're a white man therefore you have
social advantages therefore it's not bad
for me to hate you you know I can I can
say all sorts of things to you and it's
okay because you have privilege I'm
oppressed you're privileged therefore no
matter what I say to you it doesn't
matter even though in an impersonal
inter inter interaction if you say some
horrible things me I'm hurt by you know
I'm a I'm a regular person might my
white privilege isn't actually a shield
right horrible words yeah and also it
takes the distinction away from someone
from a male who is doing everything he
can to fight for women's rights in
equality and and a man who is against
those things if you just say that's
white man or it's just men and we saw
this a great example of this I think is
a couple weeks ago with those Cologne
attacks and I saw all these feminists
writing articles and tweeting saying
things are this is it's not a this isn't
a migrant problem this isn't a religion
problem they were doing everything to
get it away from the identity of the
specific people who did this and try it
well this is a male problem this is
crazy this is actually crazy
it's insane what happened in Cologne was
something called Tahoe rush Jamia which
is just Arabic the group assault or
sexual assault and it's something that
happens I think the first instance of it
was I think was originally recorded in
the 50s but I guess it kind of wasn't
something really came to the surface
until about 2011 in the Egyptian Arab
Spring huh where I excuse me a seat I
think the CNN journalist was basically
surrounded by a group of guys here in
Cairo and then molested and you know
forcibly molested by Leonid gangs of men
and this this happened on New Year's Eve
all across Europe it happened in
Stockholm Helsinki or attempted to in
multiple German cities and it was you
know the police chief literally said
nothing like this has ever happened
before
and so when feminists say well this is
just men we know that's wrong you know
we know that's wrong we know that it is
probably tied to retrograde attitudes
towards women coming from the Islamic
world you know I'm not saying every
Muslim or anything like that but you
know you you can't go to the Islamic
world and look around and see how things
are and say that women are treated the
same there as they are here right so so
that is a perfect segue to this feminist
and Islamist video that you had mirrored
who was the guy that originally created
the video right um the video was
originally done by a small a small
YouTube called site an atheist okay so
he created this cartoon video and it's a
song and it's basically a feminist and
an Islamist singing together about why
they sort of see the world in the same
way that was the thrust of it and I saw
the video and before all hell broke
loose about it before Richard Dawkins
retweeted it I saw it and I thought it
was pretty brilliant it's a it's a great
satirical takedown of this regressive
nonsense now I didn't realize at the
time that apparently the the female
character playing the piano apparently
that was actually based off a real
person right I didn't know that it's
since the Islamist the the Islamist is a
youtuber called darlin who
he runs around proclaiming his lesson
you know saying that everyone should
balance with LOM and all that sort of
thing so it wasn't you know it wasn't
victimizing anyone in particular these
are parodies of individuals but they're
individuals who have become famous
because of their terrible ideas and
attitudes right so and go ahead yeah and
I mean I had I I would love to say that
I wrote it or something but I didn't I
literally emailed the guy said I really
like your channel I want to help promote
you do me a piece of unique content that
I can put on my channel and link back to
you um and so he sent me this video and
I'm sorry I put it up and and yeah on
all hell broke loose when Richard
Dawkins retweets me so basically all
Dawkins did was retweet this and
suddenly his Twitter feed blew up and he
was deep platformed
from a speaking event at the NEC SS I
think it's the Northeast Conference of
secular skeptics skeptics and secularism
something close to that he was deep
platform from it they and they D
platform him without even telling him
there wasn't even a phone call that he
didn't ask for an explanation he then
made a public statement to virtue signal
that's the important thing they were
telling other progressives look you know
we're deep platforming him because he
has done something transgressive to us
you know and I will show everyone else
we're on where we're at the front singer
you know this is a terrible thing the
only being Richard Dawkins was probably
a big draw for that place you know me of
course you know he they might get three
four hundred people that Richard Dawkins
has millions of followers you know he's
doing them a favor so the you know
they've them they've kind of shot
themselves in the foot and they've just
made themselves but really intolerant
because his original tweet was obviously
as a feminist myself this doesn't apply
to all thumb this but there is
definitely a pernicious minority and
learn behold the pernicious minority
rose up and you know got in his face and
this I K well you're just proving the
point of the video right so you're
literally proving the point of the video
you're literally proving that these two
groups for all the wrong reasons
have become partners that there's one
ideology that that feminists
unfortunately or some degree of
feminists seem to be okay with and it's
the same ideology that would do
the worst to women yes it's hard to
believe that we even as I'm saying it
I'm thinking this is completely bonkers
it is absolutely bonkers and without
intersectional ISM it doesn't make any
sense at all you know but when again
you've got to think in Section so you
think right white person and brown
person then man woman you know and say
okay what the question is what is the
most oppressive thing so a man
oppressing the woman that's quite bad
but a white person oppressing a brown
person that's much worse and therefore
now we're talking about a bunch of brown
people being oppressed by a bunch of
white people and so the fact that men
and women are oppressing each other
Brown whether oppressing white women
that's not so important the important
bit is the skin color above the sex
which I'm genuinely surprised that I
thought feminists would go the other way
I thought that they would be more
concerned about men oppressing women
than brown people as being oppressed by
white people but apparently they're not
yeah apparently right so in your
estimation then knowing the way the
feminist movement has evolved and
obviously I've had christina hoff
sommers on the show and i've talked to
her about some of this stuff what would
you say is the bet if you just want true
equality for the sexes you're married to
a woman you you like women you know
sexual guy that likes women right what
would you say is the best way for men
and for women for anyone that cares
about the ideas of feminism to go out
and act on those ideas um I mean
honestly I think one of the problems
that feminism has now modern feminism
has is this run I have dragons to slay
you know I mean men and women have
complete legal equality I can't think of
it whenever a feminist is challenging
you to say oh you know the men are
oppressing women ask them what legal
rights men have over women they can't
name one there just aren't any and so
we're at the point now where I mean I I
don't know what more needs to be done we
seem to be living in quite stable
liberal democracies where merit matters
I mean obviously in everything it is a
lot of a lot of what it is is who you
know rather than what you know but merit
still matters you know you can't just
hire someone for their arbitrary
characteristics if they can't do the job
any no one no one thinks that so I mean
I
personally I just think don't don't make
judgments based on race or gender or you
know or transgenderism or you know
homosexuality or anything about me these
characteristics that generally aren't
very useful to judge people on I mean
you know you're being a white man
doesn't in any way inform how good an
interview you are you know I I'm I'm not
watching you because you're a white man
I'm watching you because I like the
guests you have on I like what the
questions you asked I like the answers
you get out of them you know none of
that has anything to do with you being
white or male or straight or gay or
anything like this
they're completely pointless and
arbitrary characteristics that don't
really apply right so really all we have
to do is just keep hammering the point
home right if we're for people that want
to remove this identity politics stuff
we just have to keep hammering that
until it becomes so obvious and I do
think that's where and this is where we
can sort of pivot to a little more of
the regressive tactics this is where we
can really beat them they're they're
tough to beat because we know they're
gonna lie we know they're going to cheat
and misinform people and all of those
things but what we can keep hammering
them with is we want equality for
everybody regardless of borders and
nationality and religion and everything
else
yeah the fundamentals of the fundamental
principles of liberalism are universal
that's that was the great the great gift
of sort of English liberalism is
individual rights and universal
principles they're you and then wrong
you know we've not always applied these
at you know evenly or anything like this
and initially they were exclusively for
white heterosexual men at the very top
of the pyramid but the point is that the
principles obviously lend themselves to
cascading downwards because as soon as
you have some people who are espousing
these principles there is no good reason
not to extend the franchise to everyone
which is why we now have universal
suffrage you know it you can't there's
no justification to not you know the all
of the justifications given we're all Oh
obviously faulting which is why we're
now at the point where we are um so yeah
it just basically stayed true to your
own principles if you think it's wrong
to judge by race don't judge people by
race it doesn't matter what what race
they are if you think is wrong to judge
by people by sex don't judge people
by sex you know and the all I all I can
say that these are timeless principles
that will always be relevant you know
there will never be a time where someone
says you know actually it is because I'm
black that I should be judged you know
is because I'm a woman that I should be
judged and it's only because these
people have they've got a lot of good
and very slippery language and
techniques to persuade people that in
fact you know given this context it's
right to do this whereas I'm of the
opinion that there is no context in
which it's right to judge people based
on characteristics they have no control
over you know if you didn't get to
choose it it's not a part of your
character it doesn't describe you as a
person it just describes your body or
your you know your physical
characteristics it doesn't describe what
you are like in your character so does
this do you think this also goes to the
feeling part of this because that's sort
of what I'm thinking as you're saying
this that there's there's a feeling that
I think this regressive ideology is
attached to so for example I can't give
you a as you just said I can't give you
an example where systemically in the
United States that women are oppressed
meaning that you know there are now laws
protecting you know equal opportunity
laws and things like that now that
doesn't mean that women don't have a
harder time related to certain things if
business deals for example are being
done on golf courses and less women play
golf well then there they're going to be
excluded and you could probably think of
many many examples like that but what
that is really more about is is a
feeling not sort of a systemic legal
issue and I think that's where people
that's where people struggle to to
separate these things yeah absolutely I
mean you think like um what's the what's
the company that does the sex toys and
summons and summers is a British company
I think and that it sell sex toys it's
it was created by a woman and they're a
large portion of the company is run by
women they probably don't do their
business deals on golf courses you know
they probably have I don't know massive
piles of nail salons or something like
so you know an item sounds very typical
but they don't go to getting golf
courses so I would have to change my
position of perspective and I would have
to go to where the the power is mm-hmm
that situation and don't worry you're
right you know there are going to be
cases where you have you know powerful
CEOs who go golfing and the way to get
into their good graces would be to go
girl from as well um you know sometimes
you gotta make sacrifices but I I
personally hate golfing yeah but if you
want to be the CEO of this company or
get you know I want to work my way up
the ladder I would take up golfing you
know it doesn't matter about your gender
it matters about how well you golf you
know yeah so you know I'd like so it's
not a perfect system either but it's
better than the alternative because one
thing that people will forget about
quotas is as soon as you start
discriminating in favor of someone
because of skin color sex ethnicity
whatever you are also discriminating
against people on those very same
categories you know if you say right
we've got a position here we need to
hire a black woman then you are
excluding people on the basis of their
race and sex so I I can't agree with
that I think that's wrong yeah if I'm
sure there are plenty of incredibly
talented black women out there therefore
we don't need to make artificial
adjustments surely you know and at the
end late where if we go down this road
then where does it end where where is
the eventual logical goal eventually you
come to a planned economy where you
can't you can't just have uh no wheat
wheat well you're gonna hire by merit
but now you've got you know ten
different categories you've got to go
through you know how many only
transpeople jamun queer people how many
black white Hispanic you know and so now
you're not talking about how good they
are at their jobs now you're talking
about me
just arbitrary characteristics of these
people and what happens when like if
three people leave what you do three
black people leave your company and all
you have applying for jobs and white
people what do you do yeah you know
you're in a position where it's
ridiculous yeah it's really crazy it's
almost like the the quest for equality
is being played sort of on an unequal
playing field and that just makes
everybody kind of nuts well I think I
think Nietzsche really did have it right
when he when he was saying that um you
know be careful when you're battling
monsters because when you stare long
into the abyss the abyss also stares
into you you know and if you if you
stare long into the sort of regressive
mindset of the world is terribly uneven
it's an unequal they're not
chancy's for anyone there's no end we
need to do anything we can to help them
then everything becomes justified you
know that does matter whose rights you
trample on you're doing it for the
greater good that's what really scared
so that's actually a great segue to I
want to talk about a little bit about
their tactics so I think in the in the
45 minutes or so that we've been talking
we've talked a lot about their ideas and
obviously we're not fans of their ideas
but I think there there's something more
pernicious going on here with some of
the tactics because I don't think it's a
coincidence that many of the main
players in this regressive left movement
have been exposed to be liars to be
plagiarists to be frauds to basically
manipulate people's words to create
memes that are knowingly misquoted all
of these things I don't think that's a
coincidence now you may disagree what
with what Sargon of Akkad says or what
Dave Rubin says but I don't think you
would find instances where we
maliciously misrepresented people and I
suppose they're just their argument if
you really got them alone if you could
really get an honest moment out of them
which I don't know you could get but I
suppose their argument would be well the
ends justify the means and that's just
the reverse of how I view the world yeah
now that says almost honestly that's
exactly what it is writes about it there
there's a lot to unpack here actually
there's these people are being primed in
universities to be activists and part of
the priming is to give them a good
feeling about doing this activism you
know it's to make them think that they
can emotionally reward themselves by
saying yeah I argued with a misogynist
on Twitter you know therefore oh yes oh
no I'm not kidding that that genuinely
is I've seen feminists I've seen either
pictures of feminist courses where on
the wall they have a big Twitter
activism is feminism and stuff like this
and it's just like really that's you
know this the thing they're encouraged
to be activists they they're encouraged
to emotionally reward themselves for
being activists and so do you know my
theory about never argue with the
Twitter egg that's what I'm going to put
on my tombstone one day
yeah I I haven't heard that she doesn't
give ox i i i i care about ideas and not
like people and numbers so i can when
some would like five followers says you
go wrong in this i've got to argue the
case yeah i've got a stop there wow i
might be a little more evolved than you
that's pretty good um what was I saying
um that at the schools that there
there's this there's an intellectual
incentive or there is a feeling
incentive really there's an emotional
incentive and basically it's they've got
support where they've convinced
themselves that progressive or
regressive ISM is the only morally
legitimate position to hold and so
anyone not holding this position must be
a bad person and that's everything about
progressivism in a nutshell right there
if you aren't a regressive you are a bad
person if you aren't sacrificing other
people's rights for the rights of a
group that you don't know you've got no
connection to but you have been
emotionally primed to fight for then
you're a bad person and so it's okay for
me to call you all these terrible names
I mean I you would have to be pretty
damn racist for me to call you a racist
you know it's a bad label it's a ring
it's a label with a lot of weight and
yet these people her around as if it
means nothing you know you know I always
say that I think I said this to you and
I was on your show that my awakening had
a lot to do with that whole ben affleck
sam harris thing unreal and and part of
what the craziness of was with that was
that been throughout racist so quickly
that i agree with you it would take a
lot it would take a lot there are
obvious racists out there and they
should be called out but if you were
arguing with someone it would take a
real special person for them to
illuminate that they were racist within
30 seconds I mean yeah I can only
imagine them that came straight out of
the gate with it or something either
like a black people should be under
shipped off the cotton plantations or
somehow like a well you're a racist that
on you look like well I only call myself
I wouldn't but some you know the yeah
these things normally hold a lot of
weight and they and that's the reason
they usually they use labels as weapons
and they don't for a reason for a couple
of reasons actually the first one
obviously to put you on the back foot as
soon as you're called a racist or
homophobic bigger or whatever
then you're defending yourself you're
not defending your ideas you're not
attacking their ideas you're defending
yourself as a person and that's in
itself a logical fallacy called ad
hominem you know to attack the person
rather than the ideas and you will find
that they do this a lot so basically
right the answer to this is to just say
in your opinion at the end of it so
they'll say you're a racist and you say
well in your opinion right because
they'll say you know you're a racist
you're a sexist ribbing and so in your
opinion you know I'm not and I know I'm
not and nothing that I've said would
make any reasonable people person think
that but you are not a reasonable person
and therefore you're going to label me
as a racist or big or whatever and
honestly what you've just given me is
your opinion it's not an objective
statement effect it's like when they use
the word problematic they'll say oh
that's problematic it's like what can
you explain to me what problematic meat
rights
immoral does it mean wrong doesn't mean
illegal no it means transgressive to
progressivism all to feminism and it's
basically the same as sinful in the
Catholic Church whereas the same Haram
in Islam you know it's it's the this is
transgressive to my ideology is not the
something wrong and it's not an
objective statement of fact it's I don't
like what you've done right so that I
love that because it goes to show that
they want a certain intellectual or
ideological purity and that's what the
church would want out of you or or any
sort of authoritarian view would want an
intellectual and ideological pure not
intellectual purely ideological parody
it's usually not that intellectual right
no they want an ideological ideological
purity out of you and what that does you
know I'm seeing this right now in our
democratic debate last week between
Bernie and Hillary they were arguing
over who's the bigger progressive and
it's like guys that's not what the fight
should be about it should be about if
you're on the Left it should be about
who is standing up for liberal
principles more not who fits this narrow
definition because guess what then all
you do as we've said a zillion times is
you hand the debate over to the right
and absolutely yet Donald Trump the
stewing in their own juices there as
well you know I'm the bigger
progressions to look you you don't need
to you don't need to worry about
convincing people about who's the bigger
progressive progressives are going to
vote for you you know liberal right but
the people you want to come
are the swing voters who aren't died in
the you know double progressives then
the people who aren't you know who
concern about issues okay said about
policies you know who can say about what
you're actually going to do rather than
you know ideological brownie points you
know that and so yeah it's just this
little circle jerk where they've stood
in their own ideology for so long they
don't understand how they're being
viewed from the outside and like I said
is driving people to the right you know
it's absolutely driving people so then
what what do we do because that is not
us right we're the ones we're the ones
that are trying to defend classical
liberalism I'm sure you get tons of
emails and tweets and all that stuff
that I get all the time about I see this
split this has happened I get people
telling me they're afraid and
embarrassed to call themselves on the
left I get other people saying they
won't post things on Facebook because
they don't want to get called a racist
so all these things so if there's this
growing group of people which there
absolutely is I have no doubt about it
what what do we do to keep this message
going okay um okay so the great thing
about what's happening is that the it's
interesting because I mean like I said
you had my love iane topless on your
show he was a he was the only journalist
who was prepared to cover game again
initially and I've grown to become
friends with him and people find it
really odd because he's a conservative
and I'm a liberal and I I just tried to
explain them to look right we've come to
the point where it's not really about
political affiliation to left and right
it's about whether we can agree on
reality you know we can interpret this
reality and have our own opinions in any
way I'm sure he's got a lot of things I
disagree with look we can agree that the
numbers are certain the events are as
follows you know whereas the progressive
left will lie to you they will lie to
themselves like that like we said they
will cherry-pick their narrative they'll
choose several data points leave out the
ones that contradict what they've said
and then if you don't agree with their
narrative they consider you persona non
grata you're a urine you may as well be
you know Bill O'Reilly or something like
that in that
and just to be very clear you're not
just you're not just saying something
for the sake of saying it I mean I have
literally seen this happen to me just to
be very clear I mean this is exactly
what's happened to me which I now wear
as a badge of pride by the way yes well
this is one of the things when you first
introduce people to this and they don't
know anything about it
I honestly think there is a lot of they
protect themselves with audacity and I
mean I I'm a big fan of military history
and audacity is one of those things that
wins many wars because it's so
unexpected and I really think that the
things they do are so audacious that
it's hard to persuade people they're
genuinely doing them because people hear
it and think I would never do that right
do that you know I wouldn't do I can't
imagine anyone doing it that's not
happening
you're alive you know and they think
that the person relating the information
is the one telling the lie and so the
progressives I think you know they
really bring take up on this and say
well that's because he's a racist he
sexes and all these things and then the
person that has to experience them
acting as they act to read and I've had
so many people come back to me a man I
thought you were full of nonsense
when when I first took but that was
exactly how they are they are sack and
I'm like you have made I told you
honestly don't worry about it you know
just know no harm no foul sort of thing
it's it happens to everyone because at
first when you first hear it sounds like
nonsense you know you can't believe
anyone would act this way and yet they
do do you sometimes think that maybe the
best way to beat them at this point is
just to ignore them because I think over
the last six months between what we do
here what you do what many other people
are doing especially in the digital
space now and what Bill Maher is done a
little bit more in the mainstream
there's been and they've been exposed
and I think because as you said they're
stewing in their juices now part of me
is just like let's just ignore them and
then you know then there's another piece
of me that says we have to keep on the
attack which do you think would be a
better eye or mmm is a very dangerous
tactic I think the the problem the
problem with that is that you have the
initiative to them and you say you know
I'm not going to pay attention excuse me
to what you're doing and therefore
whatever it is they do a you're not
really aware of and suddenly something
will come at you that you're not
prepared for I and all
it gives them the ground to continue
propagating their ideological position
our that gets them you know you there's
no there's no resistance and so I mean
it's it on Twitter yeah sure you know
maybe maybe there's a lot of resistance
but like if if you get a group a little
delegation of progressives who come to a
workplace and they say Oh we'd like to
talk to you about women's equality you
know go on then you know and so your
boss might like you know he's just a
good guy he doesn't know it's just
alright okay well I'll do whatever I can
you know and suddenly these people are
now advising the upper echelons of this
company and then they start enforcing
ideological conformity and then suddenly
you're in this position where I mean
this happened to major game studios it's
happen to like Games Workshop it's there
there are there are lots of people who
have fallen prey to the velvet glove of
social justice that contains within at
the iron fist yeah but it's really
well-hidden so no I I don't think we can
just I think we have to fight them we
have to show people there is a better
alternative that's the eternal point
you've got to provide a better
alternative and Universal liberal
principles in my opinion are the highest
alternative there there isn't anything
better you can't get anything more fair
than normal liberal principles so I I
honestly think just just pushing these
you know showing people these are the
best way to do things and that this not
only encourages equal treatment of
people under the law in any kind of
social situation but also it also pushes
people to be the best that they can be
it doesn't encourage them to be victims
and does urge them to get you know to be
depressing to milk it you know there's
no room for frauds when you come to
these sorts of meritocratic principles
people have to work they have to push
themselves and become better and it's
about raising the human condition rather
than dragging it down which is
everything about progressives yeah well
naturally I believe in what you're
saying and that's why I'm doing what I'm
doing yeah so I really more than
anything else I should thank you because
you know there were a couple key people
that helped my awakening and when I
had that conversation with you on your
channel it was one of the first times
that I really started talking about this
stuff so you were definitely a key piece
in that so I appreciate that and I
appreciate all the work you do and
everyone can find out more of our guns
take on gamergate feminism regressives
and plenty more over on his youtube
channel which is youtube.com slash
sargon of akkad
100 and argon Carl or you have any other
names that I need to know about nothing
let's just the two those are the big two
all right well I appreciate it and thank
you guys for watching and we'll do it
again next week
you